WITH OTHER AMERICANS JAILED
ABROAD.
HARRISON LEE'S SON IS BEING
JAILED.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
YOU HAVE A RELATIVE, YOUR
FATHER, DETAINED OVERSEAS IN
SHANGHAI ON STATE SECURITY
CHARGES.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT THOSE
CHARGES ARE POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED?
>> SURE.
SO MANY FATHER IS AN ORDINARY
AMERICAN.
HE CAME TO THE QUITE IN 1989
WITH $200 IN HIS POCKET.
HE STARTED TO WORK IN FOOD
SERVICE AND AN ORDINARY
AMERICAN.
HE RAN A ONE-MAN BUSINESS OWNER.
HE'S NOT A MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
AN ORDINARY PERSON.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE SHOCK WHEN
SUDDENLY IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016 HE
WAS TAKEN FROM US AND THE
CHARGING OF ESPIONAGE LEVIED
AGAINST HIM ARE 100% POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
THESE ARE THE EXACT SAME CHARGES
USED TO DETAIN OTHERS.
THE STATE SECRETS THAT MY FATHER
IS ALLEGED TO HAVE STOLEN IS
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE FREELY
FOUND ON THE INTERNET.
THAT ILLUSTRATES THAT IN INDEED
THE CHARGES ARE THE FALSE.
THE U.N. WORKING GROUP RULED IT
TO BE ARBITRARY AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS TAKING UP THE
CASE.
AND WHILE I'M GRATEFUL IT HAS
NOT BEEN ENOUGH.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MY FATHER IN SIX
YEARS NOW.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH LONGER IT
WILL BE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
WORKINGING HARD BUT NOT HARD
ENOUGH AND NEED TO GET TOGETHER,
PUTT TOGETHER AN INTERAGENCY
EFFORT AND ITERATE SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
REAL PLAN TO GET HIM OUT.
IT IS SIX YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW THE HOLDUP.
I WANT MY DAD HOME.
>> TELL US MORE ABOUT THE
COMMUNICATIONS YOU HAVE HAD WITH
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
>> CERTAINLY IT IS VARIED.
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE IN TOUCH WITH
THEM ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND TAKES
A VILLAGE TO RESOLVE THE CASES.
THAT'S THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION.
I GET THE SENSE THAT THERE'S
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO
WORK TOGETHER TO GET THIS DONE
AND SEEMS LIKE THE PROCESS TAKEN
MONTHS AND MONTHS AT EACH STEP
AND NOT ACCEPTABLE.
WHILE THIS IS HAPPENING YOU HAVE
INNOCENT AMERICANS BEING
TORTURED, WRONGFULLY HELD
WITHOUT COMMUNICATION.
MY FATHER'S ONLY MEANS OF
TALKING TO THE WORLD ARE THE
SEVEN-MINUTE CALLS AND MAKES IT
CLEAR HE CAN'T TELL US THE FULL
EXTENT OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
PRISON.
HE IS DIAGNOSED WITH HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE AND HAS HAD A STROKE.
HE IS CRAMMED INTO A CELL AND
SHANGHAI IS HOT AND HUMID AND NO
CLIMATE CONTROL IN THE CELL.
THEY NEED TO PLACE A GREATER
PRIOR TE AND NUMBER ONE THING TO
DO IS TO MEET WITH THE FAMILIES
THAT HE DID WITH AN OTHER
FAMILIES AND INCLUDING THE
WRONGFULLY DETAINED AMERICANS IN
CHINA.
WE ARE WAITING TO MEET WITH THE
PRESIDENT BUT HAD NO LUCK TO
DOING SO.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO?
SHOULD THEY BE PAYING RANSOMS?
A PRISONER EXCHANGE?
IF YOUR DAD COULD WATCH THIS NOW
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> CHINA I'M ALWAYS TOLD IS A
COMPLEX COUNTRY WITH THESE KINDS
OF CASES AND THE SOLUTIONS THAT
HAVE WORKED IN THE PAST THAT
THEY VARY AND I THINK THERE'S
NOT A CONSISTENT STRATEGY SO I
LEAVE IT IN THE HANDS OF THE
GOVERNMENT EXPERTS BUT RIGHT NOW
THEY NEED TO TAKE AN ACTION AND
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT WITH MY
FATHER.
TO HELP WITH THAT SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS LIKE
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER SULLIVAN THAT
PROMISED A CALL MORE THAN FIVE
MONTHS AGO THAT HASN'T TALKED TO
THE FAMILIES WE WANT TO TALK TO
HIM TO PRESENT THE SIDE OF THE
STORY TO HELP COME UP WITH A
PLAN.
WE WANT TO HELP THEM COME UP
WITH A PLAN.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO YOUR
DAD?
>> DAD, I AM JUST SO IMPRESSED
BY HOW STRONG AND RESILIENT YOU
HAVE BEEN THROUGH SIX YEARS OF
CHINESE PRISON.
I DON'T WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO YOU.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE SUFFERED
IMMENSELY FOR A CRIME YOU DID
NOT COMMIT.
I KNOW THAT THEY WANT TO WORK
HARD IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT BUT
IT IS PRIORITIZATION.
I WILL NOT GIVE UP UNTIL YOU ARE
HOME IN NEW YORK BECAUSE TO DO
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE RIGHT.